LeLe panel : Hélène Buzzetti,
MiMichel C. Auger, Alec
CaCastonguay, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Marie-Eve Proulx, député
cacaquiste de Côte-du-Sud, retie
sasa candidature. Sa Sendaï : en
plpleine campagne.
MMême si le déclenchement n'est
papas fait, on est quand même en
plpleine campagne. C'est plutôt
mamalaisant, plutôt rare. Tour e
tatable là-dessus. Hélène,
elelle dit qu'elle a prie sa
dédécision seule. On peut penser
quque le parti, en tout cas,
vovoulait éviter d'être agacé ac
cece sujet.
- - On peut le penser. Mais même
tetemps, c'est quand même étran.
LeLe premier ministre avait
dédéfendu encore les quelques
sesemaines à peine. Mais
efeffectivement, ça ressemblait
dede plus en plus à un...
vovous savez, quant à vous avez
unune ou deux personnes se
plplaignent de climats toxiques,
onon peut peut-être mettre ça sr
lele compte d'un conflit de
pepersonnalité. Lorsque vous êts
rerendus avec beaucoup plus de
nonom, voire même une vingtainee
pepersonnes qui ont quitté le
bubureau, ça devient un petit pu
plplus difficile. Il y a peut-êe
unune question plus large aussi
apapposée. C'est délicat, ce que
jeje vais dire. Ça fait plusieus
fefemmes, quand même, en positin
d'd'autorité, qui se font accusr
d'd'instaurer un climat toxiqueu
trtravail. Je pense à Nathalie
BoBondil au musée des beaux-art,
onon a eu Julie Payette, Marie
MoMonpetit, plusieurs enquêtes
jojournalistique. Il y a beaucop
dede nom. C'est à se demander sl
n'n'y a peut-être pas un
apapprentissage du pouvoir qui t
arardu et qui se fait du côté ds
fefemmes. En tout cas, il y a un
enenjeu, semble-t-il, qu'il
fafaudrait aborder. Je pense qun
esest tous un peu timide à le
fafaire. C'est délicat.
- - Ou bien que la barre n'est s
àà la même hauteur pour les
fefemmes et les hommes. Qu'on et
momoins tolérant pour les femmes
enen position de pouvoir. Bref,
MiMichel C. Auger.
- - Il se dit plusieurs choses.
BeBeaucoup de choses
cocontradictoires dans ce pointe
prpresse là. Entre autres quandn
fafait un règlement hors cour,
çaça veut dire quelque chose qud
mmême. Mais une chose est vraie,
lala raison pour laquelle il ne
sesera pas là. Elle ne veut past
onon ne peut pas à laquelle soit
unune diversion dans une campage
élélectorale. La perchaude il pt
ararriver, c'est que le jour oùe
prpremier ministre fait son avae
susur l'agriculture ou le
trtransport en commun, il y a ds
ququestions sur ce qui arrive ac
seses députés tu as des problèm.
AlAlors, à la fin, que ce soit a
dédécision ou pas, c'est pas
imimportant. Il est clair que
cacampagne ne voulait pas avoira
popossibilité, pas juste de
dédéplaire, mais de perdre...
- - Alec.
- - Je pense que sa décision et
quque François Legault l'acceptr
avavec entrain. Je pense que les
deux sont tout à fait possibles.
QuQuand elle a commencé avoir ds
didifficultés avec les membres e
sasa région, au caucus de la
cacaisse, elle n'allait pas avor
unune carrière politique
asascendante. C'est le moins qun
pupuisse dire. Elle n'allait pas
réréintégrer le conseil des
miministres. Effectivement, peu-
êêtre que ça : tant qu'à avoir
leles projecteurs sur moi
popour les mauvaises raisons,
auaussi bien partir. Et que
FrFrançois Legault a trouvé que
c'c'était une bonne idée. Mais n
n'n'a pas de candidats aux
cacandidatats pour la remplacer.
OnOn avait pas prévu ça. On avat
pepersonne à réserve au cas où.
C'C'est ce qui me fait dire quee
pepense que sa décision à elle.
SiSinon, on aurait pu trouver
ququelqu'un. Donc, au-delà de ce
ququi est ou non avéré dans son
cacabinet, je ne connais pas les
rerelations personnelles de Made
PrProulx avec son personnel, jee
sasais pas ce qui est vrai ou ps
vrvrai, mais c'est clair qu'elle
esest émue de quitter maintenan.
PlPlutôt qu'être sur le message.
AlAlors, fait une fleur à son cf
enen quittant une semaine avante
dédéclenchement.
- - Et vous dîtes que ce soit
jujuste pas, c'est la dure réalé
dede la politique.
- - C'est ça, c'est la perceptin
ququi compte.
- - Très bien, alors je le disas
: : c'est parti. Hier, les imags
dudu Parti conservateur du Québ.
OnOn a lancé la campagne, beaucp
dede monde. Monsieur Duhaime étt
llà, il disait : c'est bon pour
lala démocratie. Suivez-nous.
PrPromesse, aujourd'hui, et
dédéputés sur 365 dollars sur ue
papasse pour le transport comme
exextrait multi région. Le Québc
sosolidaire qui propose de l'aie
popour les garderies. Alors, on
esest vraiment lancé. Est-ce qun
dodoit cette année de ça?
D'D'abord, Michel. Vos premières
imimpressions.
- - Dans un système d'électionsà
dadate fixe, il ne faut pas s'en
ététonner. Mais ce qui est
ététonnant, c'est que Monsieur
LeLegault a dit à la fin de sain
paparlementaire : on frappa ça
pependant la période électorale.
OnOn voit pas d'annonce.
IlIls sont en train de faire la
CACAQ en premier. Mais à partiru
momoment où on sait, la CAQ, aux
EÉtats-Unis, les élections dures
unun an. S'il se retire pas
PuPuratone mois de septembre por
paparler. Alors, à la fin, c'est
unun peu inévitable dans le
sysystème des élections à date
fifixe. Il faudrait peut-être
réréglementer sur les dépenses.
LeLes publicités, les choses coe
çaça. Mais les promesses,
çaça n'existe qu'un discours.
- - Hélène.
- - J'abonde dans le sens de
MiMichel. Ça a toujours été le
ccôté pervers de ces élections à
dadate fixe. Outre le fait, en
plplus de comparer une année de
nonos montants devrait durer sen
lala constitution cinq ans. Et n
papas quatre. On l'oublie un pe.
MaMais oui, ça fait en sorte qul
y y a, depuis le départ, te mone
cocommence avant. On devrait,
sesemble-t-il, s'inspirer de ce
ququi se fait à Ottawa. Quoique,
enencore là, il y a des entorse.
MaMais de réglementer les dépens
prpréélectorales. Mais même ça,a
nene fonctionne que lorsqu'on
rerespecte le calendrier des
élélections à date fixe. La
dedernière élection l'année
dedernière, Monsieur Trudeau étt
alallé de manière prématurée,
etet ça ne s'était donc pas
apappliqué.
- - Il y a le facteur de date
fifixe, bien sûr. On connaît le
jojour du scrutin donc on peut
cocommencer. Mais Alec, il y a
auaussi le fait qu'il est
paparticulièrement courte.
CeCe sera particulièrement cour,
cecette campagne. Et comme
sesemblait pas perdre de temps,
onon veut être le lièvre. Et non
lala tortue.
- - Oui. Quand on est à l'avance
dadans les sondages, je ne vois
papas pourquoi François Legault
sosonnerait une plus longue
cacampagne. Le plus vite possibe
popour éviter les dérapages et e
rerendre jusqu'au bout. Mais
cocontrairement à mes collèguese
susuis un peu étonné du sans-gêe
dede ces annonces préélectorale.
LeLes parties qui ont de l'arget
fofont des publicités l'été. Mas
llà, que tous les partis envoiet
dedes communiqués de presse,
alallons électorale en bonne et
dudue forme. Des mises en scène,
DoDominique Anglade dans un
enendroit pour acheter du matérl
scscolaire de ses enfants. Des
mimises en scène dans des parcs.
LaLa campagne n'est même pas
cocommencée encore. Je pense qun
sese garderait une petite gêne n
pepeu plus longtemps. Ça fait
prpresque deux semaines qu'il ya
dedes annonces de campagnes
élélectorales. À un moment donn,
c'c'est un peu ridicule. Je
cocomprends que la CAQ le fait.
C'C'est plus porteur en tant que
gogouvernement, premier ministre
enen fonction, on peut le
prprésenter comme ministre de
l'l'environnement de la santé ce
unune annonce. Ça plus de portée
quque le candidat acquiesce quee
chchef la caisse. Mais de là à
anannoncer comme ça, chaque jou,
dedes annonces électorales alors
ququ'on n'est pas encore en
cacampagne, je trouve que ça
pepervertit le système. Je veux
vovoir qu'on sait la date, maisl
meme semble qu'on aurait pu garr
lala gêne. Ou alors faisons une
cacampagne plus longue et
asassumons-le, sinon c'est un pu
riridicule
- - oui. On a fait un tableau ac
leles slogans. On avait tous les
slslogans la semaine dernière sr
cecelui du Parti québécois. Alo,
onon va les prendre. Vous alleze
didire si c'est un bon coup ou n
mamauvais coup. Je sens que vous
alallez me dire que dans le fon,
leles slogans, on n'a pas la
prpremière journée et on n'en
paparle plus. Mais c'est
rérévélateur. Prenons un tour de
tatable sur la CAQ.
- - Je trouve que ça fonctionne
trtrès bien. Je ne suis pas si
cycynique. C'est pas ce qui
trtransforme une campagne
élélectoraliste qui fait qu'on
vovote pour un parti. Mais sauf
quque ça en capsule message de a
mimission de parti politique das
unun contexte de campagne.
EtEt dans ce cas-ci, je trouve e
çaça en capsule parfaitement la
CACAQ. "Eille, vous nous aimez,n
esespère bon dans les sondages,n
cocontinue."
- - Quand j'ai vu ça, j'ai pens,
jeje me suis souvenu de Thomas
MuMulcair quand il était chef. l
dédéfinissait tous ses discours
papar deux fois en continu.
MaMais effectivement. Elena
raraison. À un moment donné, la
seseule chose que la CAQ demande
enen réalité, c'est de continue.
D'D'avoir un autre mandat.
EtEt quand on est très en avance
cocomme ça, c'est une façon de
fafaire qui est tout à fait
nonormal. Mais d'un autre côté,i
çaça se met à aller mal dans la
cacampagne, "continuons", c'est
momoins le fun.
- - Et là, on va accélérer. Ale,
cocontinuons.
- - Pas aussi efficace que le
"M"Maintenant" de 2008, mais
ssûrement plus efficace que "On
çaça donne Legault"de 2014.
- - Prochain slogan.
VoVoter vrai, vrais enjeux, vras
sosolutions. Tour de table plus
rarapide.
- - Quand on a des longs slogan,
c'c'est qu'on a généralement la
didifficulté à encapsuler le
memessage. On essaie de dire
bebeaucoup de choses. Voter vra,
vrvrais enjeux, vraies solution.
CÇa rappelle les vraies affaires
dede Philippe Couillard en 2014.
JeJe les trouve peut-être un pet
pepeu long et moins efficace que
cecelui de 2014.
- - Michel, voter vrai.
- - Ces verbeux et un moment
dodonné, c'est d'accuser tout le
momonde de de mentir. Je ne pare
quque c'est très utile comme ça.
- - OK, Hélène.
- - Je suis d'accord. Et je ne
cocomprends pas. Je ne sais pasà
ququoi ça fait référence. Je ne
trtrouve pas efficace.
- - Bon! Le jeu de mots :
chchangez d'ère, Québec solidai.
OnOn change de façon de gouvernr
lala société. Hélène, je commene
avavec vous.
- - Je trouve que ça fonctionne
bibien. Ça représente ce que l'n
prpropose. Un changement de
paparadigme. On n'est pas les
vivieux de la CAQ, on a une
nonouvelle façon de penser, on t
momoderne et progressiste et
jejeune. Ça représente bien ce
ququ'ils offrent aux électeurs.
- - Très bien, Michel.
- - Il y a un clin d'oeil là-des
ququi est intéressant. Ce qui ne
mamarche pas, par exemple, c'est
lala photo qui va avec.
NéNéoréalisme stalinien, ça ne
mamarche pas pantoute.
- - Néo stalinien. OK!
- - J'aurais dit plus japonais e
nénéo stalinien. Mais je compres
lala référence. Le double sens,
icici, avec l'environnement,
chchanger d'air, d'époque. Ça
fofonctionne plutôt bien. Mais e
susuis d'accord que le visuel
n'n'est peut-être pas les plus
réréussis.
- - Le Parti québécois : le Quéc
s's'assomme... pour vrai.
- - Eux aussi, c'est un peu
veverbeux. Comme on disait à
prpropos de notre slogan libéra.
PaPar contre, bon, 50 qu'ils
veveulent dire. La CAQ ils sont
nanationalistes, mais ils ne vot
papas jusqu'au bout de leur
lologique. Nous, au moins on est
cocohérent. Mais c'est très long
popour un slogan. Ça témoigne de
paparti qui a de la misère à se
prprésenter et à se concevoir l-
mmême.
- - Alec.
- - C'est comme si on voulait pr
llà ne pas électorales qui est
dédéjà conquise. Ce qui ne soit
papas actuellement parce qu'ils
n'n'en font pas assez d'un point
dede vue nationaliste et
sosouverainiste. Il y en a de nf
àà 10 %. Ils sont OPQ. Est-ce qe
leles autres sont insatisfaits e
lala CAQ, ce qui trouve qu'ils n
fofont juste assez, est-ce que s
slslogans peut le rendre au Pari
ququébécois? J'en doute.
- - C'est tout le pari de la
cacampagne caquiste. De dire : l
y y a plus d'indépendantistes pr
àà aller chercher. Un gros pari.
- - Et Mononsieur Duhaime : libe
chchez nous. Qui renvoie à d'aue
slslogan d'une autre époque.
HéHélène.
- - Je le trouve très efficace.e
trtrouve que ça correspond à la
cacampagne. Monsieur James en fn
dede semaine : on était plusieus
vovouloir faire de la politiquee
gagamelle politique s'est
tetellement mêlé de nos vies.
CÇa correspond à leur électorat.
C'C'est d'une durée éphémère, ms
popour l'instant ça marche.
- - Ça rappelle le fait que ce
sosont des libertés rien à la te
dudu parti. Je ne suis pas sûr e
cecette idéologie score tant que
çaça au Québec.
- - Conclusion, Alec.
- - Court, Ponce, référence à Jn
LeLesage. Personne ne sait ce qe
çaça veut dire " ça parle à tout
lele monde. Il doit y avoir une
efefficacité autour de